en chine au japon en corée du sud où on
atteint maintenant 400 mille nouveaux
cas par jour un peu partout en asie
c'est la même chose au micro et le sou
variant ba2 gagnent du terrain son chien
sur la cre à la pandémie est encore et
toujours une urgence de santé publique
dit cet expert chinois le seul pays au
monde à maintenir une politique zéro co
vide
en europe on compte maintenant deux cent
mille nouveaux cas par jour en allemagne
s'en mêle en france et au royaume uni
surtout en raison de la progression
fulgurante du be2 qui va bientôt
détrôner son cousin au micron est propre
aux
problèmes au fait de ce fait
les états unis avec maintenant plus de
35 % des infections causées par ba2
estime qu'il n'y échapperont pas il
songe déjà à une dose de rappel
il faudrait que le béa de est de loin le
plus contagieux des variants qui nous
ont frappés on estime que chaque
personne infectée par le virus de one
pouvait 1 comptait mener deux autres
avec delta c'était quatre nouvelles
infections au micron 8es avec ba2 c'est
potentiellement 12 nouvelles infections
soit presqu'autant que le très
contagieux le virus de la rougeole mais
il faut rappeler que ce sous va rien
n'est pas plus dangereux que micron et
qu'il répond à la vaccination
la bonne nouvelle si vous voulez c'est
que les vaccins a continué d en continu
des données une protection efficace
contre le forme grave causé par le virus
au québec comme partout ailleurs une
hausse importante du nombre d'infections
est à prévoir le fait d'avoir beaucoup
de monde qui ont été infectées depuis le
mois de décembre ça contribue à ralentir
la transmission mais il reste malgré
tout plusieurs personnes qui ont jamais
rencontré le virus et qui au cours des
prochaines semaines devraient en bas le
mans a développé ces infections le sou
variant ba2 est apparu pour la première
fois en afrique du sud au mois de
décembre dernier ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal